welcome to this video on deep strategy
new handles popping up it must be I
think it's on our that's a that's not a
new handle and just have no later okay i
got a request to play more of the brayer
yeah why not it's good and my Chi go
rent is not the greatest opening a long
time so let's do it Quincy seven I know
yeah but in most cases the Queen will be
okay down I could have played g6 and
stuff first let's do this yeah this was
always in intrigue Ewing Wow interesting
for me this night to a5 idea I'm are
already a problem sir with c4 maybe I
think I have to cover this and have a
look there and before I that doesn't
look right what I did can i play c5
that's a very important question I know
that b5 hangs but if for also design
okay let's gamble down
if that's not working I would be I mean
I might be in big trouble anyway but
this is a case where this better works
ok so so at the end he will grab that
with the rook that's a big issue
hmm they are not good not good at all is
there some kind of play the second point
is also just hanging not really okay
well I don't think you can take the
second point so easily with check and
pins then but so c5 did not work really
wow ok check and see if then show me how
would this is our God Bishop f1 Bishop
a6 looks very tricky what is the point
then ok
so what what do I start Bishop c4 ideas
so now i can take you five I just wonder
if there's something better probably not
so yeah my cam I'm going to take it you
rock the one trying to win the e4 pawn
as well let's check there for a moment
Queen a1 and what if I don't play that
it doesn't make any sense night be three
mmm yeah night be three maybe
it can take this night gap if I attack
his night on the tool I've rookie one
though right look you've won Queens I
might get into some kind of fork with
Knight f3 but I don't know shouldn't
spend any more time on it not quite sure
why he's going ok that I can take with
the Queen without any folks check and
that's the phone so is there some way to
at least annoy him I have got Queenie
for write this I have avoiding the
immediate loss there of the exchange
probably here
striker used to use this night that was
a good idea not working at all great
okay if I go back it shake I'm takes me
again so I'm stepping back really not
greatest try ever to convert this thing
yeah probably i should go queen a 12 get
me away from this long diagonal okay you
went away voluntarily and it may be also
this smooth here too don't really don't
really see a clear way forward and 11 i
would like to get in g5 and 95 this kind
of stuff let's try
95 f why it would be nice he doesn't
have many move some so 95
doesn't have a check I think check it's
got this check
Oh Luke jakes everyone started working
so just cover them check check
18 seconds well check check
okay 10 seconds them check check check
check check check mate oh oh wow wow I
was one of the worst technical displays
ever with the exchange up Wow sometimes
you really get a happy end there and
then of course I was completely lost out
of the opening it really didn't look
good here right I have 2 rupee one yeah
maybe I should have thought about this a
little bit longer the c5 move it's
really well I'm worse if I cannot play
it but well if you are basically giving
away the game with c5 you should still
avoid it I could have taken a four-year
would have been a bit better right yeah
this is this is just not good at all but
I think well rookie fiber I think it's
not not really not really working yes
that's the way to lose it he can't eat
with the night down
that's surprisingly just plus one maybe
can't wear get something back there that
I don't see yeah okay I get this back
now it's not so easy technically but of
course clearly better farm and this chat
is is losing and just lose this yeah
well this is definitely this way for
improvement there check especially took
me especially long to find some other
stuff check well here black should win
somehow but has mentioned technical play
not this one not in this game well I
lucky window thanks for watching